the papers oh okay yeah that's fine too
yeah
yeah i told sigurd that he's um more
prepared than
any of us are when we present on other
papers here so we often just share the
pdf
yeah okay that's fine good okay so i'll
get started i'm gonna record it uh rj
can you
um give me permission i think it's
actually nick
uh can you click record nick yeah i just
clicked it it's recording
we're good to go okay great all right so
i'll introduce uh today's speaker sigurd
nace
who is a treasured member of the simon's
observatory he is a scientist at the
flatiron institute
he's moving to the university of oslo in
norway
and he has uh he's been a fixture
in the cosmic microwave background
community he
is the essential glue that holds
together many
of the top collaborations including the
act collaboration and today he's going
to talk about
some uh some predictions some
observations some
uh some forecasts for the atacama
cosmology telescope which is
uh run by our friends at princeton and
upenn and others
and what they can do going forward
as they attempt to measure not only the
cosmic microwave background
but also to measure the uh ancillary
features that people don't always
associate with the
uh with the science return of the
instruments that we're building namely
planet nine
not planet eight when i was a kid i'd
say planet nine are gonna look at pluto
nope they're gonna look for a ninth
planet beyond the orbit of pluto
and sigurd is going to tell us all about
what we might be able to do
with that object so sigurd please take
it away
yeah okay so i think i'll split it into
two parts here
first i'll just give a brief
introduction for the hypothesis
the planet 9 hypothesis and motivate why
it would make sense to try to look for
this and then i'll move on to the main
part which is
what we can do with act so
so
it's a sort of long and mixed history it
started with a huge success with the
discovery of neptune by looking for
perturbations
in the orbit of uranus and then that was
followed the huge range of
fiascos people predicting
planet x which was supposed to be big
and so on and
also the pluto prediction uh is it was
predicted based on perturbations of the
orbits and then it turned out to be
basically just uh at least if i remember
correctly it was
uh a lot smaller than what they thought
and
would not have caused any gravitational
perturbations at all also vulcan
was predicted in the inner shoulder
system to
uh describe the orbit of mercury
and that turned out to be a completely
wrong uh
solution to the problem too the real one
turned out to be general relativity
so um it's sort of like in that stage
that the planet
nine hypothesis was posed it's sort of
like um
when you know the history you're a bit
skeptical right out of the out of the
gate
that okay it's another one of additional
explanations to
patterns in the orbits of bodies um
and historically that hasn't had a very
good scientific
yield but they do present
an interesting scientific case so so
this hypothesis
was uh posed by
batagan and brown recently on
my show actually yeah okay yeah
so i i think it was 2016 or so they they
first
made this point and then this is a later
paper from 2019 where they
sort of summarize the state of the
hypothesis so it's a pretty good
review article um and
they have several lines of evidence but
uh i think that the
the main thing that um
like the the best summary plot is
i'll try to find it here
is this one so
basically when you look at objects far
away in the solar system objects that
are so far away
that they don't get the regular
the planets then
you see that there is some sort of
scattering here
oh did i drop out by the way no no sorry
now you go for it there you go yeah i've
got a connection
uh error so okay anyway so if you look
at those uh these
purple uh orbits here those are the ones
that are the
the most isolated from other objects in
the
closer part of the solar system and you
can see that they are very
you know they're all on one side here uh
there seems to be some sort of
anisotropy here now of course when you
see something like that
the first thing that should come to mind
is that people aren't
haven't been systematically surveying
the whole solar system for these things
people have been doing service for other
reasons and they've been
avoiding certain objects so
there will be large observational biases
so in another paper they try to look at
the size of these biases
and according to batagan and brown the
biases are not big enough to explain
this
but there have been other papers by i
think des that
make the opposite case so this is quite
controversial
but if you do believe that this
pattern actually is real then the
question is how can you explain it
and what they find is that if they
introduce
a single new planet to the solar system
at the in a moderately elliptical orbit
with a very large semi-major axis of
something like 500
au and the mass which is in between the
earth
and uranus and neptune so something like
five to ten earth masses
then you can explain all of these
patterns and a few other things
so so that's what they spend the rest of
this paper going through
okay so making the case that they can
they can find a single consistent
solution to all of these things
okay i think uh going into more details
of the of the hypothesis
itself will uh a little bit take too
much time so i'll move on to
the act part of this unless there are
any questions first
oh i guess just one quick question i had
i don't really know how
the history of planetary discovery but
is there a
is there a simple explanation for why
this wouldn't have been noticed before
is it just potentially yeah yeah yeah so
i'll come back to that for the act part
but i can say it right away
so you might ask how could such a large
planet have remained undiscovered
in the solar system you're talking about
something
considerably bigger than the earth right
but the thing is
usually planets are discovered by
looking at reflected sunlight
so light is emitted from the sun is
diluted as it moves outwards
so if the planet is has a distance r
away from the sun
then the sunlight flux will go as one
over r
squared by the time it reaches the
planet but then for us to see it
the reflected light needs to go all the
way back to earth
and that gives you another factor one
over r squared
so all together you get that the
reflected sunlight from a planet in the
outer shoulder system
goes as one over r to the fourth power
this is a very rapidly falling function
and this makes it very hard to find
uh planets which are that far away so so
usually when people find objects in the
outer solar system
you know you're looking you're talking
about stuff that's like 80 to 100 au
but here you're talking about the planet
that could be between
at the closest that would work it could
be as close as
300 au at perihelium
and at aphelion it could be as far away
as 2000 au
so those numbers are a lot higher and
you take that ratio to the fourth power
and then it's not so surprising anymore
that it wouldn't have been seen
i'll show you a plot later that
that illustrates this okay so let me
share the actual act planet nine paper
okay so um so as i said
it's hard to look for these things
optically due to the one over r to the
fourth power
power front telescopes can see it but
usually those powerful telescopes
have a narrow field of view and they're
not very efficient at looking for this
pen stars is the current telescope with
the best chance of
of seeing planet nine so
this is a plot showing the frequency of
observation on the x-axis
and the flux density on the y-axis
and the purple and blue
part here is pan stars
while the light blue part below is the
sensitivity of
lsst
other telescopes in the optical are
either too narrow field of view
or not a substantial improvement or not
competitive with penn station lsst
so stuff like sdss for example is not
deep enough to have a good chance
so so basically with the current data
available pan stars
is the only survey that could have been
expected to see it
if it's lucky um but they haven't
finished their search yet so we don't
really know the status of pan star's
observations
there are three curves here there's the
red green and blue curves
those represent an optimistic medium and
pessimistic scenario for the
detectability
of planet nine so the red one is sort of
the
the most easily observed planet at its
most
uh as its closest distance from the sun
the green one is a medium choice of all
parameters
and the blue one is the most hard to
observe type of planet nine
at its most distant and you can see that
um pan stars would
have would basically be almost sure to
see the
the the easiest possible planet nine but
the other ones are very borderline or
impossible for pan stars to see and we
would have to wait for lsst
okay so that's the situation with the
optical light
but you might not know that our best
bounds on large planets
in the solar system do not come from
optical telescopes
they come from infrared with whites
so when you're talking about planets the
size of saturn or jupiter
then wise has put the bound that a
jupiter-sized planet
cannot be closer to the sun than 82 000
au
or it would have been seen in infrared
that's really impressive right compared
to these like hundreds of au that
or roughly 100 au that you typically see
in
in the optical with a certain size one
it's more like
20 000 au but it's still a really
impressive bound
so then why hasn't y seen this planet if
it exists
well the reason for that you can see in
this part of the plot
so the the green bars here represents
the sensitivity of vice
in its four different bands
and you can see that there's
and this bump of the curves is the
thermal emission from a planet
and the second bump is the reflected so
the one we looked at previously was
reflected sunlight
and then this big bump here is direct
thermal emission from the planets
and and sigurd how much area does it
cover does wise cover and aren't they
wouldn't they be confusion limited with
stars and other background i'm doing
so white covers the whole sky
uh or yeah i think it's all sky it might
be three
three quarters of the sky but it's
really big sky area anyway
um and
i think confusion limit is not the big
problem for
for why say because they're looking for
a moving object so they can do
background subtraction
so the limiting factor would be then the
variable like a variable confusion limit
and that's a lot lower
so the big limit for y is sensitivity
here
um the problem is that unlike
like if you look at the big planet like
jupiter
then it takes a lot longer to cool down
after its formation
so when you form a planet in the outer
solar system
it forms quite hot and then it releases
even more heat as it gradually
uh shrinks over billions of years
and if you're far away enough from the
sun then this is the dominant source
of uh of energy it's not uh
the sun doesn't matter anymore so
basically the size of the planet
determines its temperature
and this is why uh weiss has such good
limits on something like
jupiter the bump the thermal bump
is not down here at like two to three
terahertz as it is for planet nine
it's all the way up here if you can see
my cursor
um yeah you can see the plot right
yeah we can see your cursor yeah so
uh for something like jupiter the the
the big peak is all the way up here and
it's excellent for
uh for wise it has huge sensitivity in
that case but as you make a planet
smaller
it gets colder and when it gets cold
enough then the thermal emission
uh drops off a cliff and that's what's
predicted to be the case for planet nine
okay so you can see here how all the
curves are sneaking below the
sensitivity
curves for um for wise
except possibly some reflected sunlight
over here
okay so if why is this too high
frequency
to be able to see the thermal emission
from planet nine
then the obvious thing to do is to go
lower in frequency
so if you go lower in frequency we have
a few other surveys
we have um iris and akari
in yellow but as you can see they're not
very sensitive
they can't really help and if you go
even further down
then the only real thing you have is act
so act i'll have the red
bars here so you can see that act would
be sort of expected to see
the easiest possible one but that's the
one that pan stars
might or might not have excluded already
depending on the status of their
analysis
and then it has a moderate chance of
seeing the the intermediate
scenario the green one and the other
curves you see here are for future
surveys that don't exist yet so the pink
ones are simon's observatory and the
older ones are cat prime
now you might ask what about something
like spt
svt has a huge telescope with high
resolution
and the same frequency coverage they go
deep on the sky
so shouldn't they be better at seeing it
well they would if they were looking at
it but the spt's at the south pole they
only look in the south
and planet nine is predicted to be
relatively close to the ecliptic
so basically spt is not looking at the
area of the sky where the planet could
be
okay and if you go even lower in
frequency then the thermal emission gets
too low and you don't have a good chance
of seeing it anymore
so so that's sort of the observational
status
of the current uh current service that
exists
the only ones that have a chance of
seeing it are
stars wise
or act
i should say hyperso prime cam is also
doing a survey even though they have a
relatively small field of view
compared to the others here so so maybe
they'll find it to
you know if it exists but
they're not quite in the same category
as the others here okay
any questions about this before i move
on to the actual
act data and our results
nope okay um did you just out of
curiosity if we look forecasted
simon's array with three arc minute
beams
but fifteen to twenty thousand detectors
is it the brain size that would just
kill us
so i haven't looked at simon's array
i've made forecasts for simon's
observatory which i'll get to at the end
but the beam is a really big problem so
you might notice that i didn't show
planck anywhere here even though planck
has good sky
coverage and otherwise would be you know
would belong on the graph
but the problem is planck's big beam
just
just disqualifies it it's it's hopeless
to find something like this with blank
and my last question is just about
cadence you know coming back and
how in terms of you know time domain
you know cadence versus um
you know beam size obviously you want
high you know cadence and high
resolution but you know can you
compensate for wanting to trade off one
versus the other or not not really
so for cadence um cadence is
not that important when it comes to this
of course you i mean you need to have
your observation spread out a bit in
time that's fine
but as long as you you know if you have
the
if you have one year where you're not
seeing anything that's not a problem
um the most important thing is a high
resolution
and a high sensitivity
and you need to be able to split your
observations into chunks of data that
are small enough that the the planet
does not move appreciably
during one of those observations
otherwise you're losing sensitivity
and it smears out yeah so that smearing
is
is the big part of the the algorithm
part of the problem here right so
um so i start by looking at whether you
can do this with the
good old blink comparison method
so that's the traditional way of finding
moving objects
you take a picture of the sky you wait a
bit you take a picture of the same part
of the sky
and then you compare them and you see
did something move between them
uh for that to work you need to have a
high enough sensitivity
that the object is individually
detectable in each of those exposures
now of course you can make each exposure
deeper just by increasing the
integration time for
each exposure but
uh if you make it too long then the
object starts moving
over you know it's moving over the time
of the exposure and you don't win
after all and i find that we are not
sensitive enough by far
to to be able to do a blink comparison
so that means we need to do the the much
more heavy process
of shift and stack analysis
so i want to go through all the details
but shift and stack basically means
you guess at the velocity of the object
then you take all the observations and
you compensate for the velocity and
of the object after you compensate you
stack and you look for objects
you get a set of candidates then you
make a new guess
okay a new guest for the velocity and
distance of the planet and you you
repeat it for all possible
velocities and distances the planet can
be
and then you look at your whole set of
candidates and then look for anything
that's statistically significant
that's how shift and stack works so it's
a lot heavier because you need to
search through a huge parameter space
so what we do is that we we make maps of
all our observations in chunks of three
days
that's long enough that we get some
depth
to reduce the amount the computational
load
and it's uh still short enough that it
doesn't move appreciably during that
time
so just to give you an impression of how
much the planet would be predicted to
move
the motion of the sky would be as much
as um
six arc minutes per year if it's at
the if it's in an elliptical orbit and
it's at its perihelion
while the more typical velocity would be
something like
two arc minutes per year
and then the parallax comes in addition
to that but it's comparable
okay so this shows our parameter search
space this plot here
it it maybe it's a bit confusing but the
base
sorry
okay so basically we have a set of
possible distances we're looking
at so the numbers at the top here that's
the distance of the planet the current
distance in
au so the closest one we're looking at
is 300 au
and then we have another bin at 321
you might ask what about 310 well that
we basically don't have enough
resolution to distinguish between
smaller steps in distance than that okay
and so on and for each distance
don't need to search through every
possible velocity
if a planet is really far away then it
won't be moving very fast
if it's close it will be moving quite
fast and you could you don't need to
search through slower motion
so that's what each of these bands there
is the dark blue band is the set the
position
the part of velocity space that i'm
searching through for 300 au
and then this light blue one that's the
philosophy space for
375 au and so on and it's split into
three panels simply because otherwise
the bands would overlap but i couldn't
draw it properly okay
okay so that's what we should search
through in total for every
pixel in the map we searched through
about 26 000
possibilities and in total the map has
of the order of 100 million pixels
so it's a quite big parameter space but
not quite so big that it gets
super computationally challenging
okay yeah i think i'll move on to the
results
so basically we find no statistically
significant detections
maybe not a big surprise or you would
have heard of it already
um you can sort of see that here okay
so this shows the distribution of
candidate
events and i show the distribution both
for the the actual search and for a sign
flipped version of the search
and the distribution looks the same
whether i flipped the sign or not
which shows that you know we don't have
any real detections
if there were a real detection then
there should have been hair down at like
one
one event there should have been
something shooting up to high
significance
for the positive search that wouldn't be
there for the negative search right
if there were a real planet present then
we would expect to see it when searching
for positive
emission but not when searching for
negative emission
so we use that non-detection to put
bounds on the on the planet
so i think the most interesting thing to
look at is to look at our distance
bounds
so how far away can we see
a planet nine
and
by the way do you see my whole desktop
or just the window
i just see the window with the plot yeah
good okay so then it's probably a
good size on the screen then yeah i'll
try to increase the resolution a bit
okay so this is a plot in right
ascension and declination
of our bounds for the minimum distance
of uh planet nine so this is shown for a
five earth mass
uh version of the planet which is the
most likely one according to batting
we also investigated the 10 earth mass
version which you can look at afterwards
but but five earth mass is like the
financial scenario
so you can see we don't cover the whole
sky we cover roughly 40 percent of the
sky which is
quite good for a ground-based cmb survey
and the color here like the colored
contours
are contours in the minimum distance so
in our shallowest areas which are like
in
blue we are sensitive up to 325
au so in those regions we exclude the
presence of a five earth mass planet 9
up to that distance now 325 au might
sound impressive
i think it's impressive at least but in
terms of planet 9 it's only
borderline useful because as i said
before the closest possible distance
planet mine
could be yet is 300 au
so we're really only excluding a small
25 au
range shutter at the its closest uh part
of its parameter space
but we have some parts of the sky that
are considerably deeper
so there's a big area over here where
we're sensitive to
up to 400 or 450 au and hereto
and then in our deepest parts we are
sensitive up to 625 au
and that's starting to be a bit
constraining for the hypothesis
for the um 10 earth mass version of
planet 9
the numbers are all a bit higher it's
starting around 450 a year or so and it
goes up to 775
au now that might sound good but
actually
it's worse than the other one because if
you make the planet more massive
then it needs to be further away to
avoid having too large an effect on the
bodies in the solar system
so a 10 earth mass planet is predicted
to be considerably further away than a 5
earth mass planet 9
and our deeper bounds here are not
enough to compensate for that
and i show that in this plot
so this is the sort of really rough
sketch
of the fraction of the parameter space
that we constrained
uh it goes from the closest possible the
planet could be
to the furthest possible it could be so
between 300 and 725 au for the five
earth mass planet line
and on the x-axis is the the fraction of
the possible sky area where the planet
could be which is basically the ecliptic
plus minus
30 degrees and the red part is the part
we exclude
and for the 10 earth mass planet 9 you
can see that we exclude even though we
go to further distances we exclude a
smaller fraction
so if we just turn that into a number
for what fraction
fraction we exclude then
that turns out to be around 13 of the
parameter space
that we probe for the five earth mass
version and
eight percent for the ten earth mass
version
but this is all really simplistic and
nobody is really given any
clear prior volume prediction for the
planet nine parameter space
it's all quite hand wavy and so it's
really hard to give a hard number on the
fraction one as excluded
but you can do a bit better than what i
showed in those figures you can take
into account that
the there is a prediction for the
position in the sky
where the planet should be at its
perihelion and aphelion
and if we take that into account we get
this plot here
so here you have the ecliptic longitude
on the x-axis
and the distance to the planet in the
y-axis
the solid lines show the closest and
furthest away
uh the planet is predicted to be and you
can see the aphelion point is predicted
to be
around 60 degrees in ecliptic longitude
and the colored contours show the
distribution
of the depth of our distance limits
so basically the the blue curve
is the zero percent quantile of our
limits then it's 10 20 30
and so on until we get to the 100
quantile our depth
so if both black curves
were below the blue curve in the plot
then we would have a 100
chance of seeing it at that longitude
if both black curves are above older
all of the colored contours then we have
a zero percent chance of seeing it
over there and if a black curve passes
through for example
this uh green
contour here then that means we have a
10 20 30
40 50 chance of seeing it at that
longitude
so that's how you read that graph and
you can
sum up all of the probabilities
and when you do that you get that
our numbers improve to having probed 17
and 9 of the parameter space
respectively
for those two planet masses so
those numbers are low enough that we
aren't surprised not to see it
you know even if you had thought that it
definitely existed which we're of course
quite skeptical of but it's still high
enough to
to be useful i think to be an
interesting contribution
and we can then look forward to future
observatories simon's observatory is
basically a continuation
of among other things oh there's a
question
no okay uh among other things act
so the esso large telescope
when combined with the act data set is
predicted to
set lower limits uh between
500 and 900 au depending on the sky
position
so that's a substantial improvement of
the current duct bounce
especially when you take into account
that to
improve this distance limit by a factor
of two
you need eight times more now 16 times
more data
right because the flux goes as one over
r squared
so and then you need
to improve the flux limit by some by a
factor two you need the factor of four
more data so
you have those two factors together and
give you a factor of 16 to improve my
factor of two
uh maybe that's not clear basically if
you have a
given as you add more and more data to a
map
the inverse variance improves linearly
with
the data you add that means that the
variance cost is one over your
integration time
but the rms level because it's the
square root of the variance
right so the rms level goes as one over
the square root of time
so if you want your noise level in the
map to go down by factor of two
you need four times more time
yeah okay
so yeah getting the limit down to and
up to 900 au in in that case is
really quite good so i think that if
lsst takes too long with their results
then so can make a real contribution
here
but when lsst comes out they will blow
everything
else out of the water okay they really
have no excuse for not
being able to see this thing i guess the
only thing would be if it's in the in
the middle of the galactic band and
there's too much confusion they they
could have a bit of problems but
overall lssc is like the the definite
solution
[Music]
but until then i think this is one of
the
one of quite few bonds that have been
put
put on the planet
okay i think that's it from my
presentation do you have any questions
yeah uh thank you sugar
super interesting uh
so what about going the other way into
near
earth objects like omua mua
which also previous guest on my podcast
avi loeb
spoke about in rhapsodic terms
that uh the reuben telescope will
absolutely smash all observatories what
can act say
about near-earth objects like those
bits of extraterrestrial technology that
visited our soldiers
we do see objects in the in the inner
solar system too
but remember this one over r to the
fourth
penalty that the optical telescopes pay
to see objects
in reflected sunlight well when you get
close
that turns around right that becomes a
bonus you know every factor of
two they get closer they get 16 times
better
so when you move into the you know when
you're talking about distances like 1au
which is sort of the where you uh this
more passed by at the closest then
optical telescopes have an
overwhelmingly huge advantage
when seeing these objects it's not like
we can't see
some of these objects we see asteroids
in the
in the asteroid belt for example but
compared to anything optical we uh
we can't compete really and um
even if you're not interested in
reflected sunlight
if you're only interested in thermal
emission then something like wise
is is much better than us we're too low
frequency um and
yeah we're too low frequency and our
beam is quite big compared to
to optical stuff so i'm sorry but i
think that
the only role of something like actor
science observatory for looking at stuff
in the
inner solar system is to
maybe stack on some objects to find like
mean spectral properties of them
or something like that yeah i think it's
quite limited what we can do there other
questions for cigarette
yeah so i saw in the abstract that you
had some
candidates uh for follow-up oh yeah yeah
we do uh but we do stress that they are
not statistically significant
they are just like out of all our
candidates they are the ones that are
the
the most likely to be something even
though we don't claim that they are
something
so you can see um you can see a list of
uh
of them here um so basically
the um the left column is our detection
statistic so um
there's a tiny uh red dot in the middle
there a bit of a bigger red dot the size
of the dot
has to do with the like what combination
of data
dominates in that part of the sky so
you know when you look at the
surroundings they look highly
significant
at least some of them but the thing is
we're doing this huge parameter search
you know 26
000 parameters search through in every
um in every pixel of the sky
and that means you can't just say that
five sigma is enough to find something
okay
the actual threshold is a lot higher so
that's why even though this one looks
super significant
it it is not really significant okay so
that's the detection statistic
the next column is what it looks like
when you take all our data
and you stack on that best fit orbital
solution
and you can see that it's yes there is
something there when you stack
but again it's it's not significant not
sufficiently significant
and then the next two columns are
standard unstacked
maps from acts they've been filtered to
emphasize
point sources and the point of those
systems to show whether there's
something
you know suspicious going on at that
location or not so that you can use that
to
reject like artifacts
there's not really anything suspicious
going on for these locations
maybe maybe this one
uh yeah so we have a set of uh of
candidate locations that uh people who
who let's say that you sit on a
telescope that's sensitive
and uh but has a really small field of
view
and where you have some free time then
you could
take the chance and look at them and i
mean you have a really small chance of
seeing something but if it just takes
you 10 minutes of telescope time to
check them then maybe that's worth it
you could get the you know you could win
the lottery
okay yeah thanks and could you describe
for me just maybe
one more time for say one of those
candidates what that stack
is like yeah yeah so uh so which
so we have something like uh was it like
seven years of act data that go into
this
and normally we map that data into
like one map per season of course you
can't do that for this sort of search
because everything would be blurry so we
map it
into like one map per day or per couple
of days
and then of course all those individual
maps aren't sensitive enough to see
anything
so you need to stack them so what that
stack column
shows is given that we thought we found
something at that location in the sky
with the given orbital parameters you
know that at the distance of 375
au in this case and the velocity of 2.2
arc minutes per year in the x direction
and minus 2.9 in the y direction
given those we can take all our
individual observations
shift them all to account for the the
motion of the object between
those observations and after doing that
we can
uh combine them to form a full map
and that's what in the stack what's in
the stack column
i see okay that makes sense so so this
the fact that you have to explore this
massive parameter space
really limits you statistically huh yeah
that's right
and this limit just gets worse and worse
the closer you try to look for things
so that's the reason why we cut off at
300 au and don't look any closer
um of course for planet nine that's not
a limitation because it couldn't be
closer than that anyway but you could
ask
when you're doing a search anyway why
don't you look for the other stuff that
could be closer after all planet nine
isn't the only hypothesis that's out
there for objects in the outer shoulder
system there's
another hypothesis called the planet x
hypothesis
which is for a smaller object that's
closer
but it's not as popular as the planet 9
hypothesis and
the thing is when you go closer
you need to consider larger velocities
and as you can see the velocity space
goes as
for each one of these distances the
the size of this annulus grows as
uh the one over the distance
squared so that's already pretty bad
right
but it gets even worse because as you
might notice
we have large spacing between the
distances at uh
at high distance you know we have one at
1500 au and then the next one is at 2000
au
at that end but at the close end we have
one at 300 au and the next one is 325 au
the reason is that the closer you get
the more motion parallax motion there is
and hence the smaller steps in distance
you can afford to take before the
difference between those parallax
motions gets too big right if if you're
wrong about the distance and you get the
wrong
parallax and then you get smearing when
you try to compensate for it
and that means that the like the
the distance step you can take in your
parameter search also goes down
when you uh try to go closer
i i don't remember exactly how the total
scaling is but i think it's something
like the the total cost of the search
goes
as one over the minimum distance to the
fourth power
a lot of those fourth powers in this uh
stuff
so let's say that we wanted to go to 150
au
instead of 300 au then
the whole thing would be 16 times as
expensive as what we did maybe even
worse
i see so you had to do that did you do
some sort of optimization of the loss of
statistical power with smearing with
like greater steps versus
velocity yeah we did there's a section
in the paper called the smearing budget
ah i see and that's all about uh
figuring out for all the different
choices of things we could do
how much smearing do we have how does
that smearing combine with our beam size
what is the effective total beam size
after taking the smearing into account
and then after all of that we we make
the choice of
step uh the resolution and velocity the
resolution
in uh distance the resolution in time
and so on so that's that's all in the
section
four four of the paper okay great thank
you
i've had my hand up for a while
oh yeah sorry i'm yeah yeah so um
the first question might actually be to
brian rather than you which is um can we
target these sources
um maybe not you but gary uh we can
probably have him
just like scan as i said maybe it just
takes 10 minutes or some things
at each of these optically oh yeah your
target man
gary cole yeah uh
yeah but i was i was going to ask a
follow-up uh
myself but uh in in lieu of time getting
late
i i think there are powerful other
telescopes that could do the job but
yeah the question of cross-correlation
with optical surveys yeah
yeah i mean obviously you want a better
telescope but
just for you know ease of you don't have
to apply
does polarization get you anything
sigurd i know that you know the gemini
planet instrument and other things you
know they do use polarization for
reflection
measurements is there any benefit from
polarimetry that we have
no no um objects
most objects tend to be polarized at a
few percent level
so when you can't even see it in total
intensity you know the chance of
detecting it
basically you need your object to be 100
sigma before you start getting anything
from polarization
that's like a rule of thumb now you have
some objects that are more polarized
than that
the cmb is a lot more polarized than a
few percent
um synchrotron tends to be quite
polarized
but uh let's say something like a planet
like uh saturn or uranus that's like
yeah less than one percent polarized i
think so
no if we if our survey was 100 times
more sensitive
then you know we could use polarization
to characterize the object
you know that's that's all we could get
from it
all right uh my other uh main question i
guess was uh what do you think of the
theory of
it's not a rocky planet but it's
something like a black hole the size of
an orange
oh yeah yeah yeah i read that paper it
was quite
quite a fun paper with like here's a
real size uh illustration of what it
would look like you know like
a few centimeters across uh yeah
i think that um
know you're starting from a clear
hypothesis which is that the planet 9
exists and then you're multiplying it by
an
unlikely hypothesis which is that we
have a huge number of uh
primordial black holes flying around and
then you get an unlikely squared
hypothesis so um
yeah but i i've thought a bit about it
it's fun to think about
because this this object would actually
appear as
if we looked at it with our telescope
and our telescope was you know
ridiculously super sensitive for some
reason
then we would see this as negative right
we would see it as
a shadow against the cosmic microwave
background
the black hole itself would be basically
zero kelvin and then the background
is 2.7 kelvin um
and so you end up with um
looking for the object as a negative
point source instead of a positive point
sort and
we don't have many negative point
sources um if you look at an individual
frequency then effectively as soon
as the orange effect appears negative
but i think this is the only other thing
i can think of that gives you a negative
point source
but if you're in certain numbers the
whole prospect of trying to detect
something like that is
uh it's ridiculously hard to detect it
and um
i think the original paper had maybe
some
uh some issue with the being overly
optimistic
about the detectability
in microwaves or something maybe that
was a follow-up paper
yeah um
yeah i mean we we do know that solar
systems have a ready supply of planets
you know so so even if promo
if we knew that all dark matter were
primordial black holes
it would still be more likely that it
was a planet i think than a black hole
but um yeah okay that's an interesting
yeah because i was
gonna bring up the dark matter thing but
you say uh
even waiting for
uh black holes is a dark matter
possibility
it's still more likely a planet than a
black hole
i i haven't done any calculation on that
okay but
uh but yeah when you look at the
expected number of planets per
solar system and the expected number of
such black holes per
solar system i i think that
my intuition at least is that the
planets win out even then
okay
okay great any other questions for
sigurd this has been a really
fascinating
and fun departure from typical cosmology
this is definitely yeah this is
planetary science i love it
this isn't what our telescope is meant
to be doing right it's really surprising
that the telescope can do something like
this at
all and one of basically only two cmb
telescopes that have a chance of doing
that the other one is
spt and it's not looking the right place
yeah
and uh yeah let's see it let's see some
exoplanet
telescopes look for uh cosmology
yeah exactly that exoplaneteers out
there who may be watching
sigrid we love uh your energy your
creativity you didn't let us down
uh thank you for being a guest at our
journal club and on the into the
impossible podcast we hope we'll get you
back again
and we wish you luck in your uh return
to
to uh to the land of scandinavia of your
birth
and uh we're looking forward to uh two
more great things from you uh
it's always a treat to hear from uh from
you you have such an inventive creative
mind
thank you so much for joining us today
sigurd
okay thanks
thank you thanks guys